hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
chapters 19 20 and 21 of alkalines
treaties on virtues and vices deal with
what could be called
matters of justice and injustice and
indeed our to some degree political
matters he's writing to
count guy who is not a monk like himself
but somebody who is secular out in the
world and indeed is part of the nobility
so this is very relevant to him but it's
also
very relevant to anybody else who would
be thinking about virtues and vices
because this deals
with the
way in which society
works and so one chapter is specifically
about avoiding fraud right another has
to do with judges and then there's this
issue of false witnesses and there's
some discussion about judges in there
going on
as well
so the central concern for all three of
these longish chapters
is indeed about justice and injustice
justice is one of the four cardinal
virtues which he is going to discuss
later so these would all fall under that
and there's also a particular
vice that
is not you know the only one that has
sway here but figures
centrally and leads to injustice and
that is of greed or
avarice one of the
eight capital vices or the seven deadly
sins and
so when it comes to fraud he says
the lord himself who admonishes us to be
generous from our substance to the poor
and wretched because he's just been
talking about um you know a little bit
earlier giving alms
forbids us all
avarice and unjust acquisition of money
and he quotes several scriptural
passages saying do not defraud each
other now is this fraud in the very
strict sense that we define it in our
legal culture no it means any sort of
way of cheating somebody out of their
money so hiring somebody and then not
paying them
could be considered fraud in this
respect um selling somebody you know
something under false pretenses you're
not actually the owner of it and we
could go on
and on
and on and
alcohol thinks that there's a mistaken
viewpoint involved here
he dwells less on the
harm or damage that is being done to the
victim of fraud and he lingers much more
over the mistaken viewpoint that happens
he says he who by any kind of fraud
acquires something because you do get
something out of fraud
loses justice and equity
say avariciously say greedily say
wickedly
what have you acquired and so
the person who's committing fraud can
say well
you know i got over on somebody or i
cheated them out of something and i
wanted to get that sob because they did
that to me or i just wanted to make a
buck you know everybody's got to make a
living we all got to eat right people
have a million different justifications
for what it is that they do and they're
committing injustice and he says
you have gotten something
but you've lost much more you've lost
faith through injustice if in the market
you were finding faith for sale if you
were good to what would you compare it
you know if you balance these things out
the higher spiritual goods and the
corporeal goods that you're allowing to
drive you
you're making a mistake a fundamental
mistake and he talks about you know the
avaricious person he says why do you
fear to lose your money and you don't
fear that you will wholly perish for the
sake of acquiring money you say false
testimony you lie you snatch on others
things you take an oath you commit
perjury since you do all these things
why do you not fear why avaricious
person do you love gold more than your
soul what is it going to profit you
in the long run and towards the end he
actually says
nothing is worse than the avaricious man
who holds his soul cheap for the sake of
the desire of riches this is a really
uh screwed up way of looking at things
avarice the vice that one has ignores
measure and when it devours everything
does not know how to be sated inwardly
it is always hungry
and needy the avaricious man is like a
depth which is never filled so the
avaricious person the greedy person
who's going to commit fraud is driven
by this vice to do things which will not
satisfy them you can't satisfy the greed
of those who always want more and more
and more even though the promise of
you know committing these fraudulent
actions that that harm oneself and harm
one's neighbor are that somehow it's
going to satisfy one right and so that's
that's you know some useful stuff to
keep in mind
this you could say the rubber hits the
road with judges in the next chapter
and he says that everyone who judges
rightly let him bear the balance you
know there's that metaphor of justice
having the balance in his hand
and there's a lot of ways in which this
has to take place how do you in fact
judge
rightly how do you enact justice within
the world justice has to be done
through judgment so your own judgment
and the judgment that you render if
you're placed in a position to exercise
power over other people and you know
given that some people are going to
commit fraud
how are you going to handle that and
there's a couple different factors here
that al quinn is going to point out
the first that he brings up is the need
to balance justice on the one side with
mercy on the other side or compassion
right misericordia
this is a very common theme
in medieval
discussions of justice so he says
for the sake of justice the judge must
return sentence for
sins for doing wrong for the sake of
mercy moderate the punishment right so
a judge shouldn't just decide
every single case exactly the same they
should you know look at the
circumstances and try not to be taken in
by liars right
then he discusses an entire host of ways
in which judges can be unsuitable
they're not good judges or even wicked
or
themselves unjust they pervert justice
and one prime example of this he says is
accepting gifts in judgment why because
gifts blind the hearts of the prudent
and turn the hearts of the just
from from god so that's a big problem
you shouldn't be taking
bribes or gifts or anything like that he
also talks about um you know not being
an acceptor of persons not giving
priority to some people over others but
another one that would tie in with the
unsuitable you can't let a stupid person
be a judge right
he goes and he says the stupid man
is uh through laziness is ignorant of
justice right so that's problematic it's
not enough just to be
a straight shooter you also got to have
some brains in order to be a decent
judge and then he goes on and he talks
about the dishonest the dishonest
through cupidity through desire for
things subverts the truth itself which
he has learned the poorer are lacerated
almost more gravely by wicked judges
than by the cruelest enemies for no
robbers as desirous of other things as
an unjust judge is the unjust judge is
really a fraud committer rather than a
fraud preventer rectifier and punisher
and he goes on as well and talks about
good judges might have bad ministers you
know they have to check on that
sometimes judges for the sake of their
desire delay or pervert
judgment they they keep holding people
out and he goes on and he talks about
another kind of judge that we have to
avoid as well
an eraskable judge a judge who is
motivated by anger or who is easily
moved to anger he says
is
such a judge is not able to consider an
examination attentively because i love
this expression from the gloom of fury
they get angry at other people they do
not see the clarity
of justice so that's that's very
problematic what is uh something that
can keep judges on track well fearing
god he says if you fear god as a judge
who is the judge of you you are not the
only judge
you're less likely to engage in these
duplicitous or predatory arrangements
you know and this this is probably you
know quite true let the judge fear god
the judge lest perhaps he'd be damned by
god
judging now you know what do we do with
judges who don't
acknowledge anything higher than them
well they're probably going to be bad
judges according to alcuin
and then we have this chapter on false
witness and he says that
false witness can include hiding the
truth right but it can also include
lying
itself and he says that each equally as
a criminal both he who hides the truth
and he who says a lie why the one who
does not want to do good the other
desires to do harm so telling lies is
doing harm and concealing the truth is
you know not wanting to do good it could
also be
trying to to engage in harm as well you
could think of and here he says
something really interesting there's
three ways
that the
lying witness the false witness is going
to be obnoxious and this is actually an
english translation of the latin term
obnoxious right
so
coming from you know uh deadly or
something like that
god
it's against god it's against the judge
and also against the
innocent person
so he says
first to god whose presence he condemns
if you're lying
you're
in a certain way opposing yourself to
god right
and
you're also
being obnoxious to the judge who you're
trying to deceive by lying and then of
course to the innocent whom he injures
by false testimony so lying is a mode of
doing injustice of wronging another
person and then he talks about four ways
that justice winds up being subverted in
judgments
and some of this applies to the people
lying some of this applies to the judges
what are these well you notice these are
four kinds of human
affectivity feelings emotions right
fear
cupidity so fear and desire
hate and love these very very basic
human emotions can go wrong
he says by fear when anyone dreads to
say or judge the truth for fear of the
power of someone right so we can be
motivated by fear to not tell the truth
about something to even lie about it the
judge could be threatened and try to you
know give a bad judgment to stay out of
harm's way or keep their family out of
harm's way
then he says um by cupidity
when a judge is corrupted by the reward
of some gift so it's not just liars
judges can be corrupted by their own
unbridled desires right
that seeking out gifts hate when he
desires to harm another for the sake of
any kind of enmity or hatred that could
apply to witnesses that could apply to
the judge as well and then by love when
a more powerful man defends friends or
relatives against justice
this is a big problem
people you know often try to you know
get get their sentences reduced or they
don't want to be called a felon or they
get community service or pick whatever
you want because they deserve it meaning
that they actually have powerful people
on their side and he says by these four
ways equity of judgment is is often
subverted and innocence is harmed right
so this is indeed
problematic and then he's got a reminder
about if you manage to escape justice in
this life those who uh here we go those
who are oppressed quickly finish their
temporal misery but those who oppress
them through injustice will be condemned
indeed here the good are often judged by
the bad you know in this world
very often times we get bad judges we
get bad witnesses we get people doing
all sorts of harm but
in the future life the evil are judged
by the good
and so in terms of you know the big
picture the long-term thing
we go back to the fraud thing there's a
mistaken conception of what's really
good for a person this leads them to
engaging in injustice which is injurious
which is unjust which is harmful
to the innocent and which the good judge
is going to have to do something about
you